here are the nine phrases you'll never
hear Mark Cuban say number one my
business has no weaknesses one of the
things I always tell people to do is you
know how would you kick your own ass you
know if you all of a sudden left your
company went to work for a competitor
what would you do what are the frailties
of your business that you would take
advantage of because every company has
them you know one of the things that
keep you up at night worrying that
people realize this you know they might
realize this part of my business has no
clothes you know so you've got to you've
got to always ask yourself how would I
kick my own ass because then you know
that that's something that that's on the
immediate list things that have to be
fixed immediately
to keep pushing you forward number two I
don't have the connections or money to
start the thing about being an
entrepreneur is this it's just all to
you you know a lot of people like to
make excuses I don't have connections I
don't have money I don't have this but
you know if you find something that you
like to do or love to do be great at it
and see if you can turn it into a
business in worst case you're gonna have
fun doing what it is you love to do in
best case you can turn it into a
business i I'm just not big on excuses I
just think if you're really everybody
has that opportunity to go forth is just
kind of do it number three nobody has
tried my idea before you've got to find
out the history of people who have tried
your idea because there's a 99.99999%
chance that your idea has been tried
before
that's not a good reason not to start it
because you might be able to outperform
them but you better learn from the
history of your idea um because you know
what they say about people who don't
learn from history number four I need to
have a great university degree to be
successful go to the cheapest school
possible to get your freshman and maybe
sophomore classes you don't need to go
to Harvard Harvard you know introduction
to writing and freshman English and
freshman sociology okay you can make an
argument it's going to be better than
you know Joe Blow junior college of our
Community College but the reality is you
have to weigh that against if you're
paying for your school or more
importantly if you're borrowing money
for your school do you want to be
saddled with 40 50 80 $100,000 and
I'll give up you know the incremental
value of freshman English at a great
school to not have the distress you know
just physically on you and your family
and I think all that's going to change
like I went to Indiana
I love Indiana I always recommend going
to Indiana are you hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo Jers
but the price for out-of-state has
gotten ridiculous and they want me to
build this building that building if
your school is building business
building buildings your school is [ __ ]
number five I don't have the traits to
be an entrepreneur there's no one set of
traits that makes a great entrepreneur
because I think everybody has it in them
to be great at something you know a lot
of people talk about passion and
determination when to me it's more about
efforts you know what are you good at
what are you not good at and then
putting in the effort to figure out how
to make it all work together to create a
company and so once you have that
figured out then you just have to go for
it and if you're willing to put in the
time you know you can you can make them
work number six I'm going to take out a
loan to start my business first of all
if you're starting a business and you
take out a loan jerem [ __ ] right
because you're there's so many
uncertainties involved with starting a
business yet the one certainty that
you'll have to have is paying back your
loan and the bank doesn't care about
your business or whoever you borrow from
unless it's family doesn't care about
your business you know and so it's just
a complete conflict number seven I
failed before and therefore can't
succeed now and I say this all the time
doesn't matter how many times you fail
you only have to be right one time then
everybody can call you an overnight
success and tell you how lucky you are
and you can be you can win the Shopify
contest number eight I'm failing because
I don't have the capital ninety nine
percent of small businesses you can
start with next to no capital it's more
about effort you know small businesses
don't fail for lack of capital they fail
for lack of brains they fail for lack of
effort
most people just aren't willing to put
in the time to work smart I mean they
they they go for it in a lot of cases
but they just don't recognize how much
works involved and
and if you do the preparation if you
know if you start a business you better
know your your industry and your company
better than anyone in the whole wide
world
because you're competing and to think
that whoever it is you're competing with
is just gonna let you come in and take
their business obviously that's naive
and I think most people don't recognize
that if you're going to compete with me
and one of my businesses you better
realize that I'm working 24 hours a day
to kick your ass number 9 I have to go
full time to start up you know
personally I think every time is the
perfect time to start a business there's
no bad times if you do the work if you
do the preparation you'll know when it's
time and it doesn't mean that it won't
be a little bit scary but you know it's
you'll know and you don't have to quit
the daytime job if you don't feel that
all that comfortable and you can give it
a run at night but whatever works for
you now with the internet you've got all
the choices in the world and you can
just go out there do your own thing and
and you know set up a business part time
don't forget to sign up for my free
newsletter its energy in your inbox
every single week hi I'm Jason Grif on
sigur rós online.com and I want to say
Evan Carmichael's newsletter is
consistent fun inspiring and it's the
only news letter I prioritize and look
forward to period